alors maintenant mikhaïl gorbatchev vous
allez être soumis à une interview un
petit peu spécial ça s'appelle la review
et on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle on
n'abuse pas pendant le jean galle
vous pensez à quoi là quand je pense que
le contact a été bon
vous avez réellement quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois
richesse réussi un enterrement de ma
femme vous changeriez quoi en vous si
vous aviez une baguette magique au
bonjour ya brillé une fois ce poison
je ne l'aurais pas utiliser cette
baguette magique y est c'est le casier
de chirico pas moi je taurine down house
si vous voulez des quelqu'un ne faut pas
lui donner du poisson il faut les
apprendre comment pêcher
si notre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi dans cette vie dont je
n'avais ni mignan eh bien je n'aurais
peut-être pas changer ma vie car en fait
je suis content de mon sort gérer isbn x
trio moi je viens d'une famille bien
pauvre dix projets siens province alors
je viens d'inde une province profonde et
je suis monté au sommet c'est quand même
quelque chose n'est pas contredit sans
fenêtre si j'avais à refaire la
pérestroïka j'aurais fait le même choix
j'ai toujours choisi la liberté la
démocratie la snes l'ouverture oui mais
j'aurais changé quelque peu mes
priorités ça c'est sûr j'aurais qu'on a
manqué de jouer les erreurs et je pense
que la pérestroïka aurait continué à ce
moment là imaginons que l époque au
début du siècle dernier
le tsar nicolas ii n'ait pas été
renversées et que la russie se soient
modernisés mais en restant dans le monde
occidental et sous le régime du tsar
peut-être une façon plus constitutionnel
est ce qu'aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle
en 2001 est-ce que vous pensez que la
russie serait plus en avance ou moins en
avance est-ce commencé que la révolution
soviétique a fait progresser globalement
globalement positif comme disait georges
marchais était le responsable du parti
communiste français
est ce que pensait que l'expérience
était globalement positif ou globalement
négative ou celle qui peut penser une
histoire il ya une délégation frangy au
prix bien en visite officielle en chine
ils sont accueillis par touring l'eau
lui pose la question suivante que
pensez-vous de la miranda de la
révolution française sur le monde et sur
la chine zhai quatre autres la chose est
bien le
ministre chinois de l'époque a répondu
ceci pascal richard à la pologne et aux
gains tendent et il est encore trop tôt
pour tirer des conclusions définitives
donc ils brûlèrent caps que les mario
cipollini comment voulez-vous faire le
bilan de la révolution d'octobre
comment aimeriez-vous mourir encore mon
heure viendra
c'est dieu qui décidera est ce que vous
croyez en dieu
et ces deux éditions du rocher mais la
motion